[Music]
the last time America created a new
military service was in 1947 when the
Air Force split off from the army
seventy years later the House of
Representatives has asked the Air Force
to reorganize and spin-off the new space
Corps but the result would not be akin
to the relationship between the Navy and
the Marines as its supporters suggest
that's because Congress would lead the
space Corps with little beyond
navigation GPS and communication
satellites it would not oversee vital
base operations including nuclear
strikes ballistic missile defense or
anti satellite missions this new service
would be less space core and more of a
satellite board the White House air
force leadership and the Secretary of
Defense have all spoken out against the
plan and it's easy to see why well it's
been touted as a way to compel the Air
Force to focus on space all it would
really do is create more Pentagon
bureaucracy instead it's best for
Congress to work with the Air Force to
strengthen our existing Space Command
let's keep America's Space Marines
relegated to science fiction to learn
more about my take on why Congress
should kill the space Corps check out
the links in the description below also
let us know what other topics you want
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI